liebes tagebuch ich habe das siebzehnte
türchen von meinem adventskalender auf
gemacht es war schokolade drin
dann habe ich meine gold glitzer
badekugeln von lush in die badewanne
gepackt aber sie ist einfach nicht
explodiert deshalb habe ich sie dann
zerquetscht ich habe thomas und henry
tschüss gesagt und dann hat henry noch
mit meinem finger gespielt er ist so
lustig dann ist die s bahn gekommen und
ich bin eingestiegen und wieder
ausgestiegen und dann bin ich ganz ganz
schnell gerannt nein spass es nun die
geschwindigkeit die video erhöht
ich musste ihn noch eine bahn einsteigen
und wieder aussteigen denn ich bin zum
potsdamer platz gefahren in berlin
laufen ganz viele menschen rum in berlin
gibt es sogar funkelnde bäume und eine
funkelnde anna es funkelt überall
sie haben sogar lebendige aufgehängt
anhand ich war ein bisschen abgelenkt
denn überall gab es angebote
dann habe ich sogar fans getroffen das
ist länder kommen das war das absolute
shoppingparadies nach dem shoppen haben
wir die money can challenge ausprobiert
und es gab asiatische spaghetti
bolognese spaghetti bolognese praline
dann sind wir noch zu mir nach hause
gefahren und ich habe wieder einen
michael buchinger wein aufgemacht ich
glaube eine höhere macht will nicht dass
wir alkohol trinken michael dabei dazu
gab es so viel und wir haben geschaut
leidet goletz co nachdem anna weg war
habe ich noch mit meinen katzen auf der
couch gekuschelt und die production
videos geschaut traum es ist so süß so
süß dann habe ich das achtzehnte türchen
aufgemacht und es war schokolade drin
ich kann schon richtig wie ein beauty
guru posen kuckuck da ist nun der letzte
sonntag vor weihnachten war kannte ich
alle kerzen an machen denn es war der
vierte advent dann haben maxi nicht ein
video gedreht er hatte richtig spaß und
thomas hat uns beim nicht geholfen wir
haben zusammen diesen pullover gebastelt
und ein lebkuchenhäuschen dann habe ich
das neunzehnte türchen aufgemacht und es
war schokolade drin
danach habe ich den katzen frühstück
gegeben nein spaß ich habe die tüte noch
aufgemacht und die portionen auf zwei
schein gerecht aufgeteilt
kaum ist möchte immer schon was von
seinem essen haben obwohl ich gar nicht
fertig bin muss ich ihnen immer runter
nehmen als der pole getrocknet war haben
wir probiert ob man ihn auch anziehen
kann und die alten richtig gut aus und
max hat vor freude salsa getanzt und so
habe ich mein essen chips fertig zum
nachtisch hatte tom ist ein kratzbaum
[Musik]
er kann auch richtig gut springen dann
habe ich das zwanzigste türchen
aufgemacht und es war schokolade drin
klar an dem tag aber nichts mehr gefilmt
nach dem anschlag auf dem berliner
weihnachtsmarkt war mir einfach noch
nichts
[Musik]
dann habe ich das 21 natürlichen
aufgemacht und das war schokolade drin
und ich habe meine bestellung von h&m
bekommen take it slow im bistum jetzt
gibt es eine kleine winterliche maker
politik von mir ich hoffe ihr habt spaß
[Musik]
rüb dem trip to make up ins gesicht und
lidschatten auch ja in die rille schön
dunkel machen schön schön schön schön
das make-up die toll aus was ist denn
das jahr augenbrauen sehen ganz schön
tracy ausbau jetzt auch wimperntusche
drauf und lippenstift jajaja leben still
dann ist ein weihnachtswunder geschehen
wachs hat den müll rausgebracht kein
spaß er bringt den hammer raus dann habe
ich die blüte einer kartoffelpflanze
nachgemalt dazu gab es noch die passende
kartoffel und beim malen durften
natürlich nicht harry potter fehlen
diese bilder werden ein
weihnachtsgeschenk für den opa von max
der hatte früher ganz viel mit
landwirtschaft zu tun und deshalb habe
ich ihn gemüse gemalt und die passende
blüte dazu und das ist eine erdbeere
ich habe nämlich noch ein bild gemalt
mit obst und der passenden blüte dazu
dann habe ich das 22 türchen aufgemacht
und es war schokolade drin und dann kam
der allerbeste moment denn ich habe
geschenke eingepackt und max glas
daneben
nach einer weile sah es wirklich
chaotisch aus und max saß daneben
das sind die geschenke die wir dieses
jahr verteilen und das habe ich von
studio 71 geschenkt bekommen dann habe
ich das 23 natürlichen aufgemacht und es
war schokolade drin und ich musste den
weihnachtsbaum abhängen weil wir über
die feiertage zu mir nach hause nach
hamburg fahren und wenn er stehen beim
würde würden in die katz nach zwei
stunden zerstören
dafür konnte ich heute bis 24
natürlichen form einem adventskalender
aufmachen und es war eine aktions karte
drin wo ist die schokolade hier nicht da
hat sie sich versteckt und zum
allerletzten mal in diesem jahr es war
schokolade drin
ich habe mir eben noch schnell meine
fingernägel weihnachtlich lackiert ganz
schlicht natürlich und so sieht unser
tannenbaum an weihnachten aus danke ihr
lieben katzen herzlichen dank jetzt sind
die adventskalender lehrer und mein
outfit für heiligabend steht und ich
wünsche euch von herzen fröhliche
feiertage verbringt sie mit euren
liebsten laßt euch reich beschenken und
denkt dran ab januar geht's wieder zum
sport